uh it's a it's an opportunity
um that i'm i'm so grateful for to to be
here
um as uh many of you been asking me what
what's carlos up to these days
so i'm i'm technically on leave from
stanford where i've been a faculty for
uh going now on on almost uh
12 years um and i've had the just
tremendous opportunity to work in the
private sector and stand up
a bio bank that's near and dear to my
heart and it's something we're calling
the biobank of the americas and in order
to stand up that biobank we've actually
built a company that um can you know
reinvest its profits in doing this uh
hopefully noble uh project that we're
excited about and i want to begin by
acknowledging uh first and foremost my
scientific colleagues and investigators
this is all
joint work with you and ashley and manny
rivas
who are um some of my closest friends at
stanford and alex yanidis who's who's
been a long-time collaborator of mine
first as a as a student and then as a as
a colleague at stanford and much of the
work that i've i'll be doing is uh um
that i'll be talking about is uh joint
work with uh with alex including um uh
the the work at the company where he's a
co-founder with me and then i also want
to acknowledge ben pinsky who runs covet
testing at stanford
and uh was just an incredible colleague
in the midst of the coveted pandemic he
um enabled us to repurpose the covet
swabs and vicky park did the lion's
share of the work and i'll tell you that
story
so i want to begin with a a major
motivation um which is
genetics today
is the main
driver for
what
molecules get put forward for drug
trials right this has been a huge shift
in the last 15 to 20 years and uh most
recently a paper came out that suggests
something like two-thirds of drug
targets
now have strong genetic evidence behind
them and uh one of the first of these
are pcsk9 inhibitors which
are molecules that lower our cholesterol
risk and these were found
first by understanding the basic
biochemistry of cholesterol transport
and then studying people who
fortuitously had a knockout mutation in
one of the genes leading to lifelong
lowered cholesterol that was then
correlated with lifelong reduction in
the risk of cardiovascular disease and
so it became this you know absolute
paradigm shift on how we should do this
because the drugs that predict your so
the genes that predict your cholesterol
predict adverse cardiovascular events
and so if you use that hypothesis you
can actually decide what drugs to bet on
and the uk biobank has now served as a
major
resource in this endeavor where
there are now four drug targets that are
being pursued at least four drug targets
being pursued after exome sequencing of
the resource and identifying these
so-called protective loss of function
mutations so it's it's really been an
extraordinary
um lift by the human genomics community
um
the the major issue and this is one that
we've been calling attention to again
for like the better part of a decade
right so
um this is not new this is unfortunately
old is that the vast majority of the
individuals upon which this work is
based are individuals of european
descent and some of this is the great
success of decodes and this is the great
success of the welcome trust case
control consortium some of this is just
you know the stagnation in terms of the
samples the nih has access to but the
bottom line is that 95 of the database
are just individuals of european descent
which means we may be leaving some
incredibly important biology on the
table
um i wish i could tell you this has
gotten better over time it is not it's
actually gotten worse um and and you can
almost think of this as you know rate of
growth of two populations one grows
faster than the other so over time in
fact the proportion of european data
gets even bigger relative to the rest of
the the sample and the the one exception
being populations of east asian ancestry
which are really largely
chinese investment in genomics and so
western scientists don't actually have
access to a lot of that data so it's
actually in terms of what pharmaceutical
companies are working on and what is the
base of the public if we want to call
that
data available it's overwhelmingly
populations of european descent and this
has massive implications
for the beautiful work that iran talked
about in polygenic risk or so this is
the transferability of polygenic risk or
across pairs of european populations
we've solved that problem um it actually
you know translates reasonably well into
populations from the americas largely
because uh populations from the americas
harbor a fair amount of european
ancestry and so the transferability is
actually a direct correlation of the
degree of european ancestry um south
asia is fascinating obviously huge you
know part of the world a third of the
the global population it depends
obviously on what south asian
populations you're talking about east
asia you know the other sort of third of
of the planet and then of course as as
often ends up being the case africa's
you know left out of this picture and
what we're learning in europe really
isn't translating very well in africa as
you might expect africa
being the ancestral homeland of all
humans has the vast majority of human
genetic variation and so we're only
studying a very small slice of diversity
space i just realized it's similar to
you know the the new telescope where
you've got the grain of sand at the tip
of your finger and we've got a beautiful
way of studying all those galaxies but
it's really just a very small part of
the sky of human genetic variation so we
started this effort largely to bring the
promise of genomics to underrepresented
populations and we're focusing on
populations where we believe there's
also going to be a rise in the value of
electronic health record data to us
thinking about this problem it's like
thinking about telecom in the 1990s do
we think they're going to want mobile
phones in latin america yes i can assure
you they're going to want mobile phones
in latin america and india and china and
so let's just jump landlines and go
straight to mobile so how would you do
that and and we're focusing initially on
the americas and and uh for two reasons
first it's probably some of the most
underrepresented uh part of the the
globe so latin america is about 650
million people 10 times the size of the
uk so you know uk's roughly 65 million
people so if you can cover 65 million
people with 500 000 then you probably
should have at least five million people
to cover 650 million people uh and they
represent less than one percent of the
current samples um the the other two
points are more kind of for the
population genetics cogniti these are
populations of mixed ancestry these are
populations with a lot of founder events
so very similar to why you'd want to
study
iceland which is an island and the uk
which is a collection of islands you
might want to study cuba the dominican
republic the lower lesser antilles the
greater antilles all of the caribbean
basin because it's full of founder
populations right on the order of
admixture that you have in uh in iceland
and other places
so um the the fundamental thesis is that
um we really believe people are willing
to jump on board and share data with us
and uh if if you actually do something
that's valuable for them and return
something that's of value for them and
you do it in a culturally aware
fashion and and that's basically the
thesis so we've gone out and actually
done the heavy lifting we've received
approval for a 10 million person study
from western irb we've built a clia cap
laboratory in miami we've started
collecting samples at scale we've um you
know really done this in the most above
board ethical way possible we've gotten
a series of advisors across the board to
help us really think about this problem
and and what i'd like to do is just show
you some of the the results we have
biobanking we have um uh informatics and
then um federated discovery
and we're starting um with covet
discards for a couple of reasons first
it's bountiful material
and will remain bound to full material
for at least some time secondly the
linking of discarded material to the
electronic health record was really
proven out by vanderbilt they built uh
just an incredible resource
and then thirdly if you've just followed
the news in the last two years we've
learned a huge amount of about the
symptoms and and
sequela of covid based on genetic
studies right it's really lit up a ton
of
conditions for example we knew very
little about the genetics of fatigue
before covid
postcovid and studying long-haulers
we're actually getting a very granular
view of all kinds of subsets of fatigue
and linking them to cell types and
molecules and hopefully we'll have time
to tell you about that
so
this is where we are today these are
operations in miami this is our bio bank
outside of miami where the community can
come and and get tested for covid and we
also do cholesterol testing and we'll
soon be rolling out additional blood
tests uh we partnered with a big free
testing site in miami that was doing
about 30 samples per day
we were in the back of a warehousing
district in hialeah florida uh about a
couple miles from where my brothers and
i grew up
and these guys are you know much better
located there on you know us-1 and you
know lots of people come in and get
tested uh this is particularly useful
when you had requirements to get tested
for flying um you you were able to get
you know up to 30 people a day and then
they had operations up and down uh south
florida so at one point we're getting a
couple hundred samples a day
um this is actual data uh bleached out
here you can't see the axis but this is
principle component one this is
principle component two in blue are our
samples and this is now a canonical sort
of pca map of diversity space where
you're taking the genotype matrix and
look at the first principal components
this is the uh sort of corner of african
um diversity space this is the corner of
european diversity space this is uh the
corner of east asian diversity space uh
this is uh um
the america's uh sort of a native
indigenous ancestry you can just see
we're doing an incredibly nice job of
covering uh the the first two principal
components you obviously look at this in
multiple dimensions and this is really
probably the most important figure i've
got to show you today again this is the
uk biobank 95 european uh one and a half
percent african less than 0.2 percent
hispanic latino this is what we were
able to do
um in in a few months of work uh it's
about twenty percent european the rest
is uh hispanic african american south
asian in this particular example we
didn't get um individuals of majority
east asian ancestry but we'll talk about
um how we can actually learn um that
part of the of the map plus uh recruit
so um here here are some uh just data on
what we've been able to collect so as of
july 1st we have 80 000 samples in the
biobank 62 000 people are recontactable
we're receiving six to seven thousand
samples a month uh last year was our
pilot year we did a little bit of
sequencing this year we're on track to
sequence close to ten thousand people we
hope to sequence 40 000 people next year
and when all is said and done we hope to
get to about two and a half million
samples in the bank of which we've um
come in to pay and sequence maybe a
hundred thousand and found partners that
want to sequence others
so the the other bit of what we're doing
is this sort of federated learning um so
if you think about the current ways that
we do
um a lot of analyses we either have to
centralize all the data or we share
summary statistics there's actually
supposed to be a computer here in the
middle but you can compute that uh for
yourself and then uh so so we've
developed a series of tools that allow
us to iterate share summary statistics
improve the model by having parts of the
likelihood travel back and and iterate
around this and see you know the
computer lights up and and so this idea
is one that we're using to federate our
algorithms across uh time and space and
so uh many countries are trying to build
bio banks and what they actually require
is standardization software and we're
part of a big global uh biobank meta
analysis initiative where we're bringing
our technology to bear on this problem
so here is um the
project we carried out at stanford um as
i said this was really just a herculean
effort by uh uh colleagues um where we
were able to take the nasopharyngeal
swabs the actual swabs that were being
used to test everybody at stanford in
the first wave of the pandemic stand up
dna and rna sequencing demonstrate that
you can actually get
at least a low-pass genome many of these
libraries have sufficient dna to take
into high coverage we were able to do
targeted hla typing uh we were actually
able to also of course do rna sequencing
of the virus and do transcriptional
profiling of the virus in the host and
do metagenomic analysis on top of that i
don't have time to tell you about all of
that so i'm just going to focus on a
couple of these uh but there's a ton of
um sort of under the hood there's a now
very nice paper in uh coming out in
nature communications on this on which
alex is a co-first author uh we
sequenced 2 000 discards out of the
first 200 000 clinic samples at stanford
we now have over a million samples uh
stored linked to electronic health
record
so here is the kind of um analysis that
you can carry out with sort of a
resource so on
the top here we have the ancestry
profiles for the coveted positive
patients and then these are time matched
controls and and you can see a couple of
fascinating features so each bar plot
here is basically like a 23andme
pie chart right so these are individuals
of african-american ancestry mostly
african about 80 african ancestry 20
european ancestry these are individuals
of of east asian and ad mixed east asian
oceanian ancestry uh these are
individuals of european ancestry these
are actually individuals of largely
native american ancestry which is not
something we see very often at stanford
and you can just see the
over-representation of green in the
covet positives versus the coven
negatives we were also able to build a
very detailed graph of community spread
including who potentially infected whom
based on the virus phenotype and then
overlaid on top the ancestry of the
patients as well as the severity um the
most interesting way of thinking about
this problem is in the time dimension
so on the x-axis here we have march
through july of 2020 so this is
literally the very first wave of the
pandemic pre-vaccine
everybody's sheltering in place you have
hispanic non-hispanic in the top right
is the first wave and then this is the
lockdown wave you can see the beginning
of this looks like very stanford
very what you would expect of people who
get seen at stanford right mostly large
suburban wealthy hospital
with a little bit of individuals of
hispanic ancestry some of which are
you know medi-cal and then in the second
half it's basically all hispanic
patients of native american ancestry um
and and so this is a lot to do with
social determinants of health and a
little bit to do with um with genetics
so how do we begin to disentangle uh
those signals there are clear real
genetic signals i'm going to start by
just making that point 100 unambiguous
there are absolutely people who are
genetically more prone to getting covert
infections and genetically more prone to
having covid
sequela and more genetically prone to
have coded severity it is simply a
consequence of the genetic lottery we've
done a large natural experiment where
you've unleashed a virus and like any
organism we have genetic variation and
this illuminates genetic variation in a
new environment it's revealing canalized
genetic variation so how do you get at
the the true genetic signals this is
where admixture plays an incredibly
important role because anybody who's
familiar with admixture mapping knows
that the individual's genome serves its
own control you can actually look for
segments that are enriched in genetic
ancestry across patients and that should
only happen based on genetic signals
because the rest of the genome should be
well calibrated and so we're using an
algorithm developed by alex and and the
rest of our team called genomics and
this is sort of the best-in-class um uh
built in in in our hands and it
supersedes the previous burst in class
that we've also built called rf mix
and and it's just an incredible
um
tool that allows us to both do the the
the
ancestry deconvolution at a local scale
but more importantly have a full
generative probabilistic model from
which we can generate synthetic
individuals to test all kinds of biases
that may creep in plus allows for us to
use the admixture itself to improve
things like phasing so here's an example
of taking the raw calls and then
superseding on top a smoother based on
recombination signals that allows to
take you know what are you know little
noisy signals and make them nice
beautiful um contiguous signals
consistent with the admixture history of
the sample
um here is the um the adversarial
network um that generates uh synthetic
individuals uh and it can take as input
um you know k different models you can
actually do multiple models both in the
generative and the inferential form
and alex can tell you
much more about it that the key is using
this idea we can now generate signals of
actual local ancestry that are
correlated with outcome and so you can
see some of the wonderful signals that
are coming off of african background and
very strong signals actually coming off
of oceanian background so you've
actually corrected away
this issue of the native american
ancestry correlating with who can and
can't shelter in place was door dashing
was not door dashing and really focused
in on segments that across individuals
are correlated this oceanian signal is
actually quite interesting because the
first wave of covid relied on a
herculean effort of
individuals of tongan ancestry that
actually were the caretakers for many of
these people who were actually sick in
the nursing homes right so there were a
couple of major tongan communities that
were very hard hit by covid and there
was differential severity based on
underlying genetic ancestry
okay so this is i think right at 19
minutes so hopefully i have a little bit
of time for um a deeper dive in into
where this goes next
again these are my herculean colleagues
involved in this for those of you who
are interested we've now stood up
something called the buy bank of
america's website you too can enroll in
and participate in this
there are ways that we can either send
you a kit or you can share existing data
with us
so the other thing that this allows us
to do is think about what may unique
what may be unique to coven what may
generalize across other
infection-triggered
sequela one of which we've been working
on for several years called pediatric
acute neuropsychiatric symptom which is
a condition that impacts children
often post strep infection that can be
triggered by others like epstein-barr
infection and there's now a huge
recognition that a lot of chronic
disease may actually have a
an infectious trigger evd being
being linked to epstein-barr and and
somebody said you know we don't call
aids long hiv right but you know it's
another example of of what would be a
chronic condition tied to an infection
um and and one of the key things that um
allowed us to differentiate the the
potential signals here are polygenic
risk scores that
are enriched in the clinical record and
it turns out if you look at
a series of different polygenic risk
force all around coagulation
including thrombosis you get a very
strong signal that people who are on the
tail of the thrombosis phenotypes end up
showing up with somewhat sick or covet
and it's very consistent with both the
cytokine storm and the acute respiratory
distress syndrome so we were able to do
is take these same signals and now try
and replicate them in a separate cohort
this is these this transpanded cohort
that i mentioned and more broadly pants
panda is part of a general set of
inflammatory brain conditions that can
follow infection including we were
talking earlier about lupus patients who
who present with neuropsychiatric
syndrome specific patients i should most
encephalitis and it's very hard to
differentiate these one from the other i
initially got involved in this because
of a massive hla signal so in the clinic
that we study we had a huge over
representation of hla b52
in pants patients versus controls um so
it was b 55 38 and 52 all were highly
over represented and what's interesting
about this is that not only does hla be
predisposed to panspandas um it also
predisposes to a condition known
kawasaki's disease and another
which which really mirrors miss c which
is the postcovid
infection in children uh because
remember you know in the early part of
the pandemic kids didn't get code and
didn't get sick from covert until they
did right and so
when
you put this all together it turns out
that sure enough these same polygenic
risk scores that we found to be
predictive of covid predicted age of
onset for panspanda as well as age at
first immunomodulation and again these
are tied to the deep vein thrombosis
phenotype so this is a cohort that
before we knew very little about the
genetics these were all kind of n of one
cases because we had this huge effort on
covid we were able to take those
learnings and not transfer them this has
huge implications for the development of
new immunomodulators the largest selling
drugs in the country are actually all uh
monoclonal antibodies that target
different
um um
you know factors that you may want to
pull down and the source of a lot of
this ends up being the tying together of
biomarkers to specific signals and so
we're in the process now of collecting
through
blood donors throughout latin america a
series of basic biochemistry cytokines
coagulation factors to build new
polygenic risk scores and thank you iran
we're going to run methylation arrays
now too because i think you're you're
100 right on this and and eventually
what we'd like to get to
are real tailored therapies that can
begin with immuno
in vitro immunoglobulins and derive all
of these products based on on the
biochemistry so with that i'm happy to
stop and and take some questions thank
you very much again it's just an
extraordinary meeting thank you roderick
and um and sandrine and the rest for
inviting
questions thank you carlos i'll take
advantage of having the microphone and
do you see associations between
variations in hla and having
long-covered symptoms now
so
yes there's um
some very interesting work um
that we're in the process of following
up on so the
key source of data for hla is bone
marrow registries
and we're
very interested right now in taking
these you know there are alleles within
alleles in hla and so some of these
signals really depend on you being able
to to identify the actual match one of
the cleanest signals
um
is actually around
this guy so
this cw
15 allele is actually a protective
allele and this allele is um
a dominant allele in india and we
actually believe that delta broke
through natural immunity that this gives
the population because you remember the
first wave of cove there was not a lot
of covert in india
okay that's the questions
ron
good question
yeah so you said that the population the
latino population is less represented
than any other one i wouldn't say less
represented than any others i would
actually say
india proportionally yeah i'm just
wondering africa for instance is this
well then yeah yeah so
i i would and actually just a follow-up
and then are you going to go to africa
as well yeah so
excellent question um
my strategy on africa is to focus on
african descent populations in the
americas for two reasons one
they're going to be highly relevant to
u.s healthcare and so we're actually
going to have data
two
african-americans or a bottlenecked
population about 200 000
african-americans came into the port of
charleston that's from which most u.s
african-americans descend they actually
have ibd patterns as you know that are
almost similar to ashkenazi
um the rest came into the caribbean and
into brazil and they came
through
really exploitation originally of this
gulf what's known as the gold coast and
then internal populations so the
administrative records of the slave
trade are so detailed you can actually
do a lot of the mapping and find
the source populations that may harbor
some of these liability alleles and
chronic kidney injury
um
prostate cancer
certain hypertension phenotypes
may be related to
the survival
of those genotypes into admix the other
is the survivorship
in native american communities
post-contact due to infection
and you almost think of it as the total
population antibody balance sheet
when when we talk about the spanish flu
it actually didn't start in spain
it started in france and actually came
from
chinese
trench diggers and so
for most of history there's actually
been a cough that starts in wuhan goes
to tehran sometimes leaps into italy and
then if it makes it into the americas
the severity actually travels in that
direction so
u.s native american populations were
very hard hit by covid
even though they worked harder than
almost any other group the indian health
service did a herculean job to get
everybody bass get everybody
vaccinated they still had particularly
bad adverse outcomes and in
brazil it's of course the native
communities that are particularly hard
hit so i think there are real hla
signals and immunity signals there we've
seen this from signals of selection
just in general in the genome and so
that becomes a circumscribed problem
obviously i'd love to do more work in
africa and i was part of the original h3
african advisory committee i think it's
just it is a very difficult
problem and i think africa is building
institutions to try to tackle that and
the best thing i can do just from you
know being
me and who i've got access to is to
really tackle the local populations and
then work like we've done before we've
done a lot of work on the transatlantic
slave trade and ancient dna there that
ties it back to the continent so
you know that that's an incredibly
interesting area the other is of course
the middle east which has
very interesting population genetic
patterns that
are now
beginning to be illuminated with changes
in stigmatization of carrier status and
so on
super interesting
sorry
great great talk carl um quick questions
about like hla diversity given how kind
of censored the previous registries have
been on like are you discovering
novel hla
yeah yeah like do you have an estimate
about how kind of under sampled or under
ascertained they are
so
i
not really i mean i would say
um
there is
so we have an effort right now to
actually do hla typing on every blood
sample that we receive
and try to enroll as many of those
people in bone marrow registry programs
precisely for that reason so we're
actually building
a free bone marrow registry program in
colombia and we're going to clone it in
other places if we can and that's part
of our strategy because that begins with
at least course hla typing of what goes
into the registries
comparably like the be the match
registry is about 10 million donors
if we can make a dent and we get the two
and a half million people that we have
hla on that's like 25 of what would go
into that that registry program
um and there's a that's actually a great
place to go sample because many people
get like okay i can help
not only
my family but somebody else um but we
don't have estimates yet we're we're
working on it alejandra's how your hand
up yeah i just was uh regarding the
together like the survey
you have them like for establishing like
collaborations which is the minimal
information that people should have
great question we have a pretty detailed
health survey that that we um
that we use and then the other is
because we run a clia cap lab we
actually um
if we're doing a clinical test can
actually access the health care data off
of the exchanges one big thing we're
interested in
is tying
survey and
really patient reported outcome data
with ehr data this is particularly
true for the the kids with pants panda
and the long haulers right these long
hauler surveys
the investigators who do long haul have
ocd i mean they're ridiculous right like
and so there's a huge interest in these
especially
in the tails you know people who just
you know went down the drain because of
covet or something like that and and
there i think we're getting pretty good
ways of subtyping the
the the phenotypes
thank you i think that in the
long covet symptoms slide you mentioned
few lab measurements uh clp
procalcitonin etc
what is the relation for of them to
the
long cove with the well it it it's sorry
i think uh
anyway it's in the last biomarker slide
um
so d dimer and crp were just routinely
collected as as part of
as as
part of the existing
um
set of phenotypes and so the prs's for
those
you know are borderline interesting but
you know general inflammation and and
breaking that down
okay other questions
yeah i think that's it uh let's thanks
carlos again thank you thank you so much
the passes won't get here but uh
but it should be anytime soon
but
when we joined it